We're now going to all have a series
of lectures on how pathogens evolve.
The first lecture we'll deal with
pathogen causing very islands.
The second with how the Microbiota are
managed and the distinction between
symbiotes and pathogens.
The third with how pathogens have
evolved to evade and suppress the immune
system.
The fourth deals with an
extremely important problem,
the rapid evolution of
antibiotic resistance and
the fifth concerns therapies
that can mitigate the consequences
of that kind of evolution.
Pathogens have their own agendas,
they respond flexibly in rapidly
to anything that we do to them.
And you can think of them as being
primarily interested in their own
reproductive success and not really being
at all interested in what happens to
you,
either good or bad.
So let's first discuss
pathogen caused very ones.
And the key idea here is the tradeoff
between virulence and transmission.
Another is the distinction between
vertical and horizontal transmission.
And the third is the distinction
between single and multiple infections.
Each one of these contrasts affects
intrinsic pathogen virulence.
Now virulence is caused both by direct
pathogen effects and by host responses
we've just seen in the last
set of lectures how many
diseases there are that are
associated with the immune response.
Virulence is always an interaction
between pathogen and host,
and in these lectures we are analyzing
the portion of damage done to the host
that is caused by properties that are
intrinsic to the pathogen rather than by
the host response.
The first idea here is that there is a
trade off between the virulence of the
pathogen and the probability
that it will be transmitted.
And the example that brought that idea
to the forefront is Myxoma virus in
rabbits.
So the Myxoma virus is a
member of the pox virus family.
It's transmitted by mosquitoes or fleas,
ticks and Mites.
So it's an arbovirus.
It causes tumors,
but not immediate death in
cottontail rabbits in the Americas,
but in European rabbits, the genus
or rectal as it causes myxomatosis,
which is an acute disease that
initially has a 100% mortality rate.
Now it is European rabbits who
were brought into Australia.
Myxomatosis was introduced to Australia
to control their devastating outbreak.
There were no natural predators of
European rabbits and they were essentially
grazing the countryside
right down to the dirt.
Both the pathogen and
the host then evolved.
The pathogen evolve less virulence and
better resistance evolved in the host.
Virulence did decline,
so virulence did go down,
but myxoma remained quite very lengthy.
Infected rabbits at the end
still only survive for 20 days.
So this is how virulent strains changed.
They identified five grades of
virulence by case fatality rates.
So real and great one had more than 99%
case fatality rate down through Vereal.
That's great.
Five which had less than 50% the mean
survival time was less than 13 days for
various grade one and quite long,
quite a bit longer than 50 days
for Vereal inch grade five.
These rows indicate time periods between
1950 and 1981 what you can see is that
initially 100% of the strains
of Myxoma virus were great.
One.
They lost very once,
but they essentially evolved into
virulence grade three here in the middle,
which still has a case fatality
rate of between about 50 and 70%.
So the way this works is that
if the rabbit dies quickly,
there's very little opportunity for fleas
and other biting insects that transmit
the disease. The less virulent
forms that can then out compete,
the more virulent forms because
they have superior transmission.
Okay.
However, they do worse while
doing worse in a single host,
they are doing better in
the population as a whole.
Okay.
No. The hosts also evolved
genetic resistance and they
do have adaptive immunity.
Okay.
So the take home point from the Myxoma
virus in Australia is that there's often
a trade off between Varian once and
transmission from the pathogens point of
view.
This trade off is a major problem.
If the pathogen is only living in
this host, if it also has other hosts,
then that's not so much of a problem.
If this problem is not solved
a host specific pathogen,
we'll go locally extinct because it
will essentially kill all of its hosts
before it can transmit out of them,
which is what happened in
the initial eval epidemics.
Yeah.
The second major issue with very Lynch's
vertical versus horizontal versus
vector transmission.
Strictly vertical transmission,
which is a transmission
from parent to offspring,
selects for low virulence and
eventually for commensalism this.
In other words,
this is pathogen transmission,
which is mimicking the transmission
of genes from parents to offspring.
Strictly horizontal transmission.
That is no transmission
from parent to offspring,
but all transmission between individuals
who are of the same age class and not
necessarily related.
It selects for Highbury ones
selection for virulence with vector
transmission depends on the impact of
virulence on the efficacy of the vector.
So in vector borne diseases,
the genome of the pathogen has to be
able to deal with both the host and with
the vector that gets it to the host and
they can often have different kinds of
immune systems.
Waterborne horizontally transmitted
diseases, uh, have major impact.
So here are a few of the major
health problems. On the planet,
typhoid fever, cholera,
amoebic, dysentery,
rotavirus and Basler dysentery.
The annual deaths that are being caused
by these diseases continue at high
levels,
so we're seeing in some
more than a million,
about a million and a half deaths
annually from waterborne diseases.
Now,
this is why the clean water
that's provided by a modern
sewage system has such a
huge impact on human survival.
Yeah.
Another major determinant of the intrinsic
virulence of pathogens is thought to
be weather infection
is single or multiple,
just the host infected just by one strain
of pathogen or by multiple strains.
And first we have effects that
are mediated by host mortality,
so multiple infection will select
for increased intrinsic virulence.
If the impact of the parasites on the
host is through the mortality of the host.
Then competition among strains for
representation and trends in transmission
modifies the virulence
transmission trade off.
Because to be transmitted, the pathogen
has to dominate the competition,
but in doing so,
it damages the host.
So virulence is going to increase because
the competing pathogens or is a pro is
a byproduct of their
competition damaging the host.
They can't avoid doing so because if one
of them doesn't do what the other one
will.
However,
if the effects are mediated by host growth
or host condition rather than by the
death of the host,
if they have sub lethal effects,
and if those effects feedback to the
parasites to reduce their rate of
development. So we're
slowly, slowly growing.
Host or a host in poor condition is one
in which the parasites cannot develop as
rapidly.
Then multiplicity of infection
generally leads to lower variance.
So this is a complex one
to summarize.
Virulence intrinsic to pathogens increases
when anything affects the virulence
transmission tradeoff.
Anything shifts transmission
from vertical to horizontal.
Anything increases the
frequency of multiple infections
that have more impact on
mortality than on growth.
So virulence is a characteristic of
pathogens that can evolve in response to
these sorts of conditions.